j'ai une question pour vous qui se
douche plus d'une fois par semaine
c'est mon dixième des français y a des
yeux d'une foule ya des gens lisent a
dit en rigolant une fois par semaine
mais collet je tirais cas mais on sait
les chroniques à merde bah je n'avais
pas senti on ne parlera avec le docteur
saldmann juste après
les français champion du monde de la
mauvaise hygiène
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit mais une
enquête ifop menée auprès de 2500
habitants européens les français
sont-ils salle oui selon une étude ifop
pour diogène france publié dans le
parisien et les chiffres sont parlants
76 % seulement cela tous les jours 73%
des hommes changent de sous vêtements
chaque matin est juste 25 % des français
se lave les mains après s'être mouché et
comprend mieux le taux de transmission
covit dans le pays vient frictionner au
moins 30 secondes et avec du savon le
geste peut sembler simple il est
pourtant loin d'être un réflexe pour
tout le monde bref tout ça ça fait quand
même un paquet gros dégueulasse et la
mauvaise hygiène apparemment pas que
dans les foyers puisque au travail
seulement 17% des français utiliseraient
les sanitaires par manque de propreté de
papier toilette ou même de savon et pour
ceux qui ne peuvent directement se laver
les mains mieux vaut être équipé d'un
gel hydroalcoolique pour ceux qui se
sentiraient concernés par ces chiffres
une mise au point s'impose notre dose de
l'été va vous donner toutes les astuces
pour garder une hygiène irréprochable
comment rester propre merci dr seulement
être avec nous la santé devant soi alors
là j'ai toutes les questions à vous
poser déjà 73 % des hommes change de
slip tous les jours
les gens quand même quand même 21 des
hommes change de slip deux fois par
semaine elles
sont des hommes changent une fois par
semaine à % tous les quinze jours et à %
n'importe pas son paquet d'avants chez
les femmes 94% change de strips tous les
jours 4% change de culotte deux fois par
semaine et à % tous les quinze jours et
ça fait mal
alors déjà dr sanoh la note première
question est ce qu'il est nécessaire de
se laver tous les jours alors oui du
sans hésiter ça fait du bien de prendre
une douche c'est bien ce en commençant
par le haut et pignard alors si vous
n'arrivez à vous doucher en commençant
par les soldats tombent dans oz fort
quand même avec la douche chez on
commence mais on se lave c'est important
on pense à ce bien se laver aussi les
mains se brosser les ont pas ce que sous
les ongles ça peut être la jungle on
s'aperçut que les gens qui se ronge les
ongles une mauvaise haleine pourquoi
parce qu elle charme fait qu plein la
bouche
dans le fait qu c lagarde chaque montée
car oui d'accord d'entre elles également
il ya une petite chose il ya beaucoup de
français qui souffrent à peu près 40% de
troubles type hémorroïdes fissures
anales ma risque et s'est régalé à une
mauvaise hygiène de sion un terreau
fessiers et pour bien laver il faut se
fait accroupis messai la main et on se
met il faut s'abonner à cesser chez
parce que le papier c'est pas vraiment
formidable vous savez papier sa masse
est rompu avec la chaleur on a
alors choisi avec ça est-ce que se laver
à l'eau ça suffit non pas du tout il
faut frotter sa bon et d'huile de coude
vial excusez moi juste une question on
dit et là c'est ça rit on dit qu'il faut
pas se mettre du savant tout le temps
parce que ça abîme la peau serre que
marianne sage une douche sur deux le les
savons aujourd'hui les gels douches ne
sont pas bon pour la peau n'entendant
l'apprendre de salon de savants trop
agressif bien sûr mais une fois par
choix ya pas de soucis ce qu'ils font à
savon
ya ça chez moi est ce que c'est bien
grâce à vous si c'est celle pour
l'hygiène intime oui jamais journée
pour les impliquant souvent des poires
non tu mets du d'utilité sur le titre
alors aller chez le médecin
je dirais que pour la femme il faut
jamais mettre de sa vraie on part le
barça bien que ça casse la flore et ça
peut faire l'inversé des problèmes
d'accord réfection donc on assiste ce
serait bien non non non très bien mais
faut-il oui pardon excusez moi je veux
vraiment amener appuyer sur ce point
parce que malheureusement que quelqu'un
de jeune fille non mais c'est vrai
qu'ils ceux qui suivent les réseaux
sociaux et qui après bon faire des
douches vaginales ou des bains vaginaux
et c'est la der c'est très dangereux je
voulais que le docteur vous précise que
la femme a le seul appareil génital qui
ce qui sort de nouakchott c'est vraiment
pas à ça sera la honte ou nettoyant la
wii
[Rires]
c'est
au fond me remettra les pieds dans la
machine
alors faut-il obligatoirement changer de
sous vêtements tous les we are we were
pas convivialité pour les autres oui
alors je confirme et entend créer de ça
que les femmes sont beaucoup plus
propres que les horaires larges chemins
mehr avons de grands chemins c'est vrai
largement merci d'apple yona quijote
[Applaudissements]
machinalement il n'y a pas photo mais
quoi il ya des hommes qui retournent
leurs slips pour pas le changer
ah oui quand-même s alors il paraît
alors il paraît qu'il faut protéger je
joue je vous cite un il faut protéger
son ami
lance pas de 10 à la fin sont
scc des mots qu'il déclenche et bien sûr
cette fois regardez là beaucoup
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait beaucoup regardé
beaucoup trop mal
c'est très important parce que vous
savez la région de l'anus et très
sensible c'est un sur oki comme la peau
qu'on a sous les paupières c'est pour ça
qu'on essaie ça coûte les yeux de la
tête
c'est donc qu'il est à pors le papier
photo irritant et vous me savonner
rincez séchez et sa vie de bien des
troupes dans à ce niveau bien sûr il ya
énormément de français qui souffrent de
ces pathologies liées au fait que sa
masse est réservé est alors moi j'ai une
vraie question pas parfois on fait pour
le matin et on va direct sous la douche
si on met le g qu'elle fut dans le trou
de balle
comme je n'ai rien inventé
non non non plus chez merci non
l'anthropologue si on se met plutôt
accomplie on savait des princes bon ça
ce n'est pas de l'agression est malin
et très agressive
alors est-il dangereux 2 alors c'est un
jour de ne pas porter de sous-vêtements
oui avec
un homme aux urgences il portait pas de
sous-vêtements chantier qui brutalement
à remonter sa fermeture éclair
tennis
il ya une bulle qui coincé dans la fin
on a régulièrement des accidents a eu il
ya cela d'autre part comme les gens ne
changent pas forcément de pantalon tous
les jours un moment donné ça devient un
taudis mais oui on les fera comment j'ai
une question quand on a
la
gauche car quand je pense que son
émission commence dans dans 20 minutes
le ballet du déclin par dan huss grave
vous avez pété les plombs
j'ai une autre question
non non non non non non non répond pas
des sessions très peu goûté à la mettez
de l'eau ça sent
mauvais temps il va c'est une fuite
[Musique]
ratier
[Applaudissements]
les docteurs ne répondait pas cette
personne en danger l'avenir
c'est quand même bien merci
est-ce qu'on peut porter un vêtement
qu'on vient d'acheter il vaut mieux le
laver parce qu'il ya énormément de
produits mais il faut s'en débarrasser
moi je conseille de laver et porter
ensuite n'avait d'accord très bien alors
plus ses besoins qu'ils essayent donc
c'est un coup à trouver oui c'est un
échange de deux groupes pour rien non
rien bien sûr mais ce fait davantage et
ce qu'ils foutent avait alors comment il
faut se laver les mains deux fois par
jour alors il faut se laver les mains
bien sûr avant de passer à table qu'on
rentre à la maison mais une chose que
les gens connaissent pas du tout c'est
se laver les mains avant d'aller aux
toilettes parce que vous allez toucher
forcément pour faire pipi votre organe a
défini la raison oui mais quelque part
dans un tel flux rires et puis si vous
avez les mains pleines de microbes et
vous allez on se ment c'est ton bien se
laver les mains avant et après après
bien sûr c'est moins grave en fait tous
en fête se ruiner stérile a très bien
c'est très propre mais c'est bon ça sent
du corps j'ai tout à fait il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de bactéries
dangereuses dans les urines non non j'ai
fait il ya très longtemps une étude sur
les bol de cacahuètes dans les cafés on
avait trouvé 14 sorte d'urines par bol
de cacahuètes parce que les messieurs
aller faire pipi se lavait pas les mères
replonger dans les cacahuètes que c'est
bon les gars car les gens ont beaucoup
parlé mais c'était pas grave l'uriné
stérile c'était juste une question de
goût
très bien merci pour ces précisions qui
sont donc on se pose on en a beaucoup
parlé avec le caue vide est-ce que les
gels hydroalcooliques sont pas
finalement un peu nocifs voire dangereux
non alors quand on a rien d'autre sous
la main c'est utile mais c'est pas pour
bénir les mains avec du gel
hydroalcoolique il faut de l'huile ne
coûte faut frotter faut entre quand on
veut bien savez les mains faut frotter
au niveau des ongles faut frotter dans
les espaces interdigitaux parce que
c'est là où se mettent en quatre les
germes les microbes mais beaucoup de
gens pour cette faune sera rien il faut
y aller il faut y aller alors on ait
pensé à elle avait aussi vos bijoux et
vos bagues
je te dis pas les bijoux les bijoux la
pensée aux bijoux
[Applaudissements]
6e 12 que de une fois par jour alors
jaguar pense que père ça vous ennuie à
deux fois au minimum va ou encore je
rends le matin quand je rentre le soir
même des fines oui oui mais pointant par
jour combien de fois par jour deux fois
deux fois et deux fois aimez-vous deux
fois une fois le matin une fois le soir
et vous le jeudi
[Rires]
une famille en fête qui ne se en fait
qui ne se lave pas regarder ces éditions
du moment vous n'avez pas l'élan que
vous l'avez très souvent c'est quoi
votre moyenne ça va être une fois par
semaine fin reçu au mollet gauche une
fois par semaine touche et les cheveux
bruns les cheveux c'est pareil c'est
aussi penser mais des fois il c'est
parce que je mette pas de shampooing
j'avais juste comme une ado tu te lave
les dents tu quand j'y pense c'est à
dire quand tu y penses mais quand j'y
pense ben deux fois par semaine c'est
tout est là tu les as l'avait pour venir
sur plateau non sérieusement c'est juste
que j'ai fait un banc debout je vois
juste prix de l'eau gérard ceiops c'est
bon elle fait que voir
étape à des problèmes de tas de débris
alimentaires non pas spécialement alors
il ya ça y'a des gars pas les dents il
ya ceux qui savent pas les pieds et des
mains qui marche pieds nus ont des pieds
des guns excellent gardien
on adore marcher tout le temps quand
nuit en fête ben alors marchez vous
marchez pied d'une habitude oui oui
thomas un bel arbre
à ouidah corps et sa salle en fait
après vous allez allez
ben oui mais enfin papa la non en fait
je pas pouvoir mais ce soir vous allez
vous l'avez oui bon peut-être pas
forcément fait moi oui moi en tout cas
oui
bon ok
c'est crade vous vous sentez propres on
sent pas plus grave que ça baba pour
tenter dégueulasse alors j'ai utilisé
parce que moi j'ai un grand débat moi je
veux laver les cheveux une fois par mois
par exemple non c'est pas là je vous
jure c'est vrai des deux fois mais en
fait il pas exclu que son chef trop les
cheveux on perd ses cheveux oui mais
bien sûr le trop est l'ennemi du mieux
mais là c'est un peu juste la niche
trois fois par mois c'est suffisant mais
parfois une fois pour le moins une fois
par semaine ce qui veut dire c'est que
t'es un gros dégueulasse non non alors
je ne puis pas du cuir chevelu du doubs
et surtout mes cheveux sont bas son ex
et tu as de beaux cheveux donc une trêve
au chaud j'ai encore des questions pour
le docteur saldmann est ce qui me fait
le ménage chez soi tous les jours oui
alors c'est une bonne idée mais bien
faire le ménage c'est utile c'est plus
sain il faut penser par exemple un
oreiller au bout de deux ans 10% son
poids ses des acariens mort ou des
déjections à la carrière incroyable
qu'il faut penser le ménage en fait
c'est très technique faut penser aux
points de vulnérabilité faut la payer
des centaines de petites règles si on
connaît les règles on passe au travers
des centaines à la wii à vous passer un
bac pro vous pouvez pas le choix si oui
je m'écoutais qu'investir le frigo deux
fois par mois pour le laver ça fait on
l'allumé parce qu'il y ait des le frigo
microbes qui se développe dedans qui
sont dangereux pour la santé et les les
toilettes tous les jours l'étoile bien
évidemment j'avais quand enlever ses
chaussures comme on arrive à la maison
évidemment parce que si on ramène de
l'extérieur la merde à l'extérieur à
l'intérieur le faille à sion c'est un
vrai et grand tour à microbes donc ça
sert pas à grand chose me iweins du tout
il faut que dans chaque pièce avoir les
bons réflexes
si vous avez les toilettes dans la salle
de bains faut pas laisser la brosse à
dents qui va récupérer les germes tient
un petit reflex jonathan borlée sa dent
quand les américains vont aux toilettes
ils baissent le couvercle y tirer la
chasse d'eau après oui mais les français
ils sont tellement fiers de ce qu'ils
ont fait regarde il tire la chasse aux
il respire et une étude a montré que
quand on fait ça s'appelle l'effet
aérosols mains des microbes plainte
relâche plein la gorge plein les poumons
et ça fait 30 % des infections
respiratoires se rebiffe un bon réflexe
je ne fais jamais mais
jamais en faire à partir de 2000
habitants comme ça connaître franchement
ça bits est malade pour rien merci
beaucoup de personnes menacées